it's the question everyone asks after a
mass shooting how did this happen
again unfortunately we already know the
answer we don't have sufficient gun
control laws and we can thank the NRA
for that the National Rifle
Association's mission is to defeat any
legislation that might restrict gun
ownership that includes the assault
weapons ban that has been proposed
repeatedly since 2004 prohibited under
that ban would have been the rifles used
in the San Bernardino Newtown and Aurora
shootings
after many of these attacks the NRA
defended assault rifles and specifically
they are 15 as necessary for civilian
self-defense and for hunting the only
thing that stops a bad guy with a gun is
a good guy with a gun
more recently the NRA fought against the
law they would have stopped anybody on
the FBI's no-fly list from purchasing
firearms more than 2,000 people on that
list purchased weapons since 2004 so why
didn't any of this legislation pass well
the NRA gave a lot of money to
politicians who voted against it take
senator Mitch McConnell for example the
NRA has spent over $1,000,000 supporting
the senator which is probably why he
voted against the no-fly no gun
legislation recently McConnell said that
the NRA needed to give its approval
before Supreme Court nominee Merrick
garland could be appointed I can't
imagine that a Republican majority in
the United States Senate would want to
confirm in a lame-duck session a nominee
opposed by the National Rifle
Association but it goes far beyond him
the NRA is very effective in getting the
right people into office 90% of NRA
endorsed candidates win their elections
in the 2014 elections alone the NRA
shelled out twenty eight million dollars
including the communities devastated by
mass shootings in Arizona they
bankrolled representative martha
mcsally's Biddeford Gabby Giffords old
seat Giffords you may remember took a
bullet to the head during a mass
shooting in 2011 the NRA worked to
ensure her successor opposed gun control
but the scary thing is the NRA doesn't
just focus on political spending its
grip on government so tight but they've
made sure the CDC can't research
anything related to gun control
meaning our data on gun violence is
practically non-existent it also spends
hundreds of millions of dollars to a
tax-exempt foundation and has trained 28
million children with its gun safety
program it really is an all-encompassing
campaign so will we ever be able to pass
gun control legislation as long as the
NRA is against it hey guys I'm recording
this the morning after the shooting in
Las Vegas and yet again people in
America are asking the same questions
about guns that they had after orlando
and after Sandy Hook so we've put
together a playlist of some of our best
content on guns there's videos on the
NRA videos on gun control and videos on
public health so please click through
and check those out and has ever
subscribe to aj+ for more content like
this